فيديو
حسن ما فهمته بانك اعددتها خطاب جيدا جدا
جدا
حوار بيني وبينك فاسمح لي ان ابدا بطرحي
سؤال بسيط فهمه الجميع
تحدثنا عن اجتماعاتك
الثلاثاء الماضيه خاصه فيما يخص الصين
عقد السلسله رائعه من الاجتماعات
3 قمم يوم امس
الاولى هي قمه المجتمع الخليجيه المعتاده
والتي تركزه على التحسين وانمو المستمر
وفي التعاون بين دول الخليج كما اعلنا
اعلن صاحب السمو وانا سنقترح رؤيه متجدده
لمشتعون الخليجي لدينا ما يسمى برؤيه
الملك سلمان لبرنامج الخليجي والذين جمع
العديد من الاندماج الاقتصاديه الذي
شهدناه والان نعمل على تقديم النسخه
المحدثه منها وبعد ذلك
خليجي والصين وقامت العرب والصين
كانت كلها الاجتماعات الاولى على مثلها
جدا ان يزيد يتعاون لنا مع اكبر شركه يعني
التجاريين الصين هي اكبر شركه تجاري صفقات
المنتخب العربيه السعوديه
وخوض هذا لحوار مع ثاني اكبر اقتصاد في
العالم بنسبه لنا امر مهم جدا بينما نستمر
ببناء شركات في البيئه العالميه بشكل اا
نحصل فيه على فرص الازدهار وتطور للجميع
هذه البيئه العالميه كيف ترون نفسكم فيها
خاصه مع كل التوترات المستمره بين امريكا
والصين والحرب في اوكرانيا وغيرها
وخاصه فيما يشمل انتاج النفط من وجهه
نظرنا الاستقطاب هو اخر ما نحن بحاجه اليه
الى الان سبق مشاهدنا الضغوطين على
الاقتصاد العالمي هو النسب التضخم وامن
الغذاء والمزيد من الاستغفار ليس سبيل
لحلها فقط
تعزيز العلاقات ومجالات التعاون همم
كانت تعبير عن ذلك
جده مع الولايات المتحده هذه المحاوله
لبناء الجسر مع كافه هنا على العالمين
وهذه المملكه خامس 10 اكبر اقتصاد بالعالم
واسرع اقتصادات النمو في العالم ونعمل
خلال هذا العام والمره
الدولار في الناتج المحلي الاجمالي فا نحن
همم
تنمو اهميتنا في الاقتصاد العالمي
ومركز او
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وموقف الخليجي
هو بناء الجسور بين الشرق والغرب ونرغب
بالبناء عليها وكذلك معالجه كل التحديات
التي نواجهها نحن نعيش في عالم معقد وصعب
ودائما ستكون هنالك مسائل يجب ان تعالج
ولكن افضل سبيل معالجتها عبر الحوار
والتفاعل والتعاون هذه مقاربه
همم ضمن سيادتكم الخارجيه هل تقبلون
باستخدام المصطلحات تعدد التحالفات
تعدد عدم التحالف ما الذي تفضلها المساله
التحالفات بالايجادي مجالات التعاون
بالنسبه لنا الخارجيه مدفوعه بحاجتنا
لبناء
للشعب السعودي اولا ولي الشعبي المنطقه
والشعوب العالم وانا اتطلعه لكافه الفرصه
للبناء على تحقيق هذه الاهداف فان كانت
هنالك فرصه للعامله مع الشريك على المسرح
العالمي لتعزيز يقدراتنا وتحسين وتقويه
برامجنا الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه
من طاقتها فلا يحصل ذلك الا عبر التعاون
فسوف نتبعه هذه المسارات
ولكن ان كنتم مهتمين في
تقليصي التوترات كما قلتم في هذا العالم
المعقد بما انكم لم تصبحوا قوى عظمى بعد
فاكبر الاطراف الامريكي والصينه عليهما
الموافقه على فكره
هو هدف مرغوب به فهل تعتقدون
بان امريكا والصين اليوم مستعدان للتخليص
او خط التوترات لا استطيع التحدث عن
رغباتهم ولكن اقول لك بانه قناعتنا هي
انهم يجب ان يخطفوا التراث
ذاته
جميعا نحن في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
همم كما قلنا 15 اكبر اقتصاد بالعالم
بحلول 20 30 يتوقعوا بين العشره الاوائل
لم نكون افضل ولكن جزء من عالم من امين
شهد اصوات العالم وكل الدول المهتمه
بمستقبل مشرق من خلال اتحاد مع كافه
شركائنا والتركيز على المستقبل والتعاون
المنافسه امرا جيد
ولكن المنافسه التي تقود الى النزاعات هذا
شيء سيء وتضر بالجميع
وستكون عاملا مزعزا
تزيد من احتمالاته المجاعه في العالم
النامي والحرماني وما شابه فعلينا التركيز
على بنائه الجسور والتعاون وعلينا التفكير
في بناء الازدهار المستدامه لدولنا وكذلك
المجتمع الدولي
اا ان ستدي كوشنر
الخاص
بيدن
حاسبه فهمنا زارا المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
ما قرانا الصحف لكن فعل ذلك لانه تتوقع ان
اوباك وانتم ستوافقون على زياده الانتاج
فماذا
تقولون عن ذلك نستطيع ان نقول العربيه
السعوديه
استقرار الاسواق في اوقات الصعبه اذا ما
عدنا لعام 2019 2020 عندما مواجهتنا
الجايه واحنا لا كبير على الاسواق وبعض
الاسعار سلبيه في بعض الاجسام التي تتعالى
انتاج الطاقه وقادت الى قيوده على الاسواق
تدخلنا وعدنا الاسواق الى مرحله التوازن
نستمر بفعل ذلك اذا ما نظرنا الى السوق
النفطه مقارنه في سوق الغاز او مسافه
مقارنه باسواقي الفحم سترون بان ان ان كان
مستقر مقارنه بكافه مصادر الطاقه المتجدده
لاننا بشكل مفعل في تحقيق الاستقرار
للاسواق تحدثنا مع كافه الشركائه الى
امريكا وغيرهم واوضحنا مقاربهنا
اوكلاس الاخير عوده الى اكتوبر
عندما اعلنا عن
المليونير المليونير دولار علينا ان
نتذكره
بان السعر يجب ان يكون موصف للمستهلك
وكذلك للمزود لانه بدون سعر
المزودين سوف يتوقفون عن الاستثمارات وهم
قال لك استقرار للست مراتي اصلا في مجال
الهيدروكربونات
الخضراء وغيرها ولكن على الماده البعيد قد
يكون ذلك مناسبا امر على هذا القصير
والمتوسط فهذه المشكله لان
القدرات اذا ما استمر بالانخفاض واذا
لاحظنا تعاطي في الصين ونعمل جميعا ان ان
يحصل ذلك واذا ما
الاقتصاد فسوف يكون هناك خط كبير جدا بسبب
الافتقار الى
الاستثماراته والاسبل الوحيد اللي ضماري
الاستثمارتي لردعناع عن الصدمات على بدا
القصير والمتوسط فقط اذا كان الاسعار نصفه
المستهلك واللي مزود هي من الصفه الان
والاهم من كل شيء انها مستقره ويعني ان
المستثمرين سواء كانوا حكومه وشركات كبرت
كانها ترى الاحتمال التي استقرار الاسواق
الان وفي المستقبل وهذا يعني انهم
قرارات الاستثمار وفقا لهذا الاستقرار ولا
نرى ذلك في اسواق الطاقه الاخرى هذه
اولويه القصوى وهذا هو واجب
وتحقيق الاسعار شكرا جزيلا
هذا جواب دقيق بشكل عام ماذا لكن تحدثنا
عن علاقاتي السعوديه وروسيا
تجمعنا العلاقات
قويه جدا
ونحاول ان نطوره ونعمله عن كتب
خاصه
لكل المجتمع الدولي وقد عبرنا عن راينا في
جمعيه العامه لها الامم المتحده ولكن
الاكرمه
بالحوار او لويتنا هي الحوار وهذا يعني
التحدث مع روسيا ولازمنا
كاندي
معه تجمعنا بهما علاقات جيده ولا حضرنا
بان هذه العلاقه ساعدت على سبيل المثال في
استبدال بعض الاسرى بامكاننا البناء على
هذه العلاقاتي والثقه من اجل المساعده في
تطوير الحوار نحن نستمر برعايه الحواري
بين روسيا واوكرانيا
ومثل لاعرف الكثيرون هو اننا
تجاري علاقتناكرانيا قبل النساء كانت اكبر
ما كانت عليه مع روسيا فتجمعنا علاقات
قويه بين الطرفين
ونحن نركز على استمرار برعايه امكانيات
الحوار وهذا النزاه في الختام لا يمكن
حلها الا بالحوار وعلينا تركيز على ذلك
الكثير من الخبراء
والمراقبين اشتكوا من ان سياسات الولايات
المتحده في الشرق الاوسط
ليست واضحه تماما وهذا اقل ما يقال وهذا
ربما يكون له تبيعات جديه
لانه كما يقولون بان الطبيعه ترطب الفراغ
على ذلك
بلا شك اعتقد بان الولايات المتحده امام
هادور هام هذا الدور بالتاكيد ياتيناه هو
ان تتفاعل بشكل كبير اهم متفاعلون ويدينا
حوارات جيده مع شركائنا في امريكا
بدوني
بحاجه الى حوار استراتيجيه حقيقي وهذا
الشيء يحصل على مستوى الثنائي وكذلك على
مستوى الخليج والولايات المتحده اعتقد ان
امريكا تلعب دورا هاما لو تستمر بلاعبي
هذا الدور في المنطقه خاصه من الناحيه
الامنيه
واذا ما قارنتم بيد
شامبو او حتى اوباما
هل هنالك
اختلافات واضحه
المختلفه
السياسات مختلفه بين الاداره الجمهوريه
والاداره الديمقراطيه فبلها تكون هناك
اختلافات واضحه ولكن في الختام المصالح
الامريكيه هي نفسها اذا ما كانت الاداره
جمهوريه او ديمقراطيه فربما تكون
مقاربتهم تجاه هذه المصالحه مختلفه ولكن
جماعتنا علاقات قويه جدا ما عم يركع عبر
اداره مختلفه جمهوريه وديمقراطيه على
التعامل مع
الاختلافات هناك
اعتقد ان المصالح استبقى هي لسه هو مستمره
في المستقبل ومجالات التعاون بين المملكه
والخليج والولايات المتحده ستبقى قويه
اذا
ماذا عن الاتفاق النووي السؤال مزدوج في
الحقيقه هل هنالك
هل لا تزال هنالك فرصه
لانقاذ هذا على الاتفاق امم هل من ان او
مؤكدا اني راسه يحق لناويه وان حصل ذلك
كما لا يستفعلون هل لا تزال هنالك فرصه
بلا شك دائما هنالك فرصه لا استطيع ان
اقول انه لا توجد فرصه ولكن ما اسالك هي
هو هل التوصل الى اتفاقناوي هل يعني ذلك
ان ايران لن تصبح دوله نوويه لكل دوله لها
سلاح ناوي لا اعرف انا متشكك مع ذلك نحن
نستمر
بالدعم همم
ولكن هذه النقطه بدايه وليست النقط نهايه
نقطه بدايه
لمعالجه بعض النقاط العجزه والضعف في
الارتفاع همم
علامه الاسفها الان همم
بحاجه الى مزيد من الضمانه
واذا علمنا صدع الاتفاق نووي فسوف ندخل في
مرحله معقده جدا وخطره علينا تجنبها معقول
ذلك حتى انا عدنا اتفاقناوي فلست متاكدا
من ان هذه هي خطوه نهائيه بل علينا ان
نبحث فيما بعدها توصيل الاتفاق اقوى
هلك ان تحدثنا المزيد عن ذلك ماذا سيحصل
اذا ما حصل
ت ايران احنا ناوي
سوف
خطيره جدا في المنطقه سبق وان تشاهدنا
نشاطات كبيره من ايران وسوف نرى مخاطر
اكبر بكثير كما انا دول علم الطاقه لن
ترغب بان تعرض لمثل هذا الخطر من دون رده
فعل فدوى العلم البطاقه بلا شك سوف تسعى
لضمان امنيها
سعوديه
اتحاد الاوروبي وسعوديه و فرنسا انا من
فرنسا فاودونا نعرف
بدانا في العام الماضي
استراتيجيه مع الاتحاد الاوروبيه بين
الخليج العربي
تجاريين هو شركه التكنولوجيا
كثيره مع اوروبا واستطيع ان اقول بانه يجب
ان تكون متفاعله بشكل اكبر مع هذه المنطقه
كثير ما نستطيع ان نقدمها اوروبا
نحن شركه طاقات هامه ونحن نشارك هامه جدا
لتحول الطاقه اوروبا لا يمكن ان تحقق
اهداف حياته الكربون من دون هذه المنطقه
لاننا همم
اوروبا المملكه ودوله اخرى في المنطقه
القدرات الهيدروجين الاخضر والطاقه
الشمسيه وطاقه الرياح
والقدره على التصديرها للطاقه الخضراء الى
اوروبا ومناطقه اخرى فسوف نكون شريكا
اساسيا لاوروبا
الى غايتي القرن الجديده والمطوره هذه
العلاقه والعلاقه بين السعوديه وفرنسا
قويه جدا وانا رئيسه بشكل كبير في المنطقه
ونشه جدا في عمله مع شركاء فرنسا في
المنطقه همم بيننا علاقات عامه رائعه جدا
مع النظر عن الفرنسيين سواء كانت في
المجال الاقتصادي او السياسي للتعامل مع
ملفات المنطقه سواء لبنان او ايران او
غيرها نحن نتطلع لتعزيز هذه العلاقه
وتقويتها وفرنسا كما قلت كانت اتباقيه جدا
وهذا شيء نحن
الدقيقه
لتحدثيه عن الاوضاع المحليه
الكثيرون في اوروبا بالتحديد لا يفهمون ما
يجري في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
فهناك اشياء كثيره جاريه في المملكه ولكن
قبل ذلك هل هنالك اي سؤال لحامه الشؤون
الخارجيه الذي لم اطرح
ما كنت ودي افترض
يعني
شو الخارجي فانا اتصل بك الى استفسرها منك
ان كان هناك اي شخص هنا يعتقد انه هناك
سؤال هام لم اطرحها وهذا وارد جدا
[موسيقى]
انا اتحدث عن الشؤون الدوليه والعالميه
امر على اتفاقات الابراهيميه ما هو السؤال
ما الجواب
ان كان السؤال
بالجواب
استطيع ان اقول لك الجواب
الجواب هو الدوله فلسطين او دوله فلسطينيه
في المره القادمه
التي تشرفوا بجلس معاك
دوله فلسطين
بيبي 5
دقائق متبقيه
وربما
انت تمثل الجيل الجديد
للقاده في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وانت تتحدث
اللغه الالمانيه بقدر اجازتك الى اللغه
الانجليزيه
الى العالم
حدثنا في بعض كلمات حول رؤيتك لبلادك
اليوم والحلم
السعوديين الشباب
للجيل القادم
انا متقدم في السنه انا في اخر اربعنات
و70% من السعوديين اعماره 35 بالنسبه لهم
انا من الاجيال القديمه ولكن يسعدنا انه
ساهم هيك فريق قدر تحت قياده جلاله الملك
صاحب السمو ولي العهد الرسمي مستقبل هذا
الجيل الشاب
اعتقد اننا نعيشه او اوقات مثيره جدا
بالعمل في المكان العربيه السعوديه همم
نحن همم
نعيش والتغيرات جذريه
والاهم من كل شيء نحن نعمل تحت خارطه
الطريق واضحه ورؤيه واضحه وكما قلت مسبقا
نحن نبني الازدهار المستدام للشعب السعودي
وهذا هو
الاولويه والدفع الرئيسي لكل ما تقوم به
المملكه العربيه السعوديه سواء كانت
السياسه المحليه او الخارجيه فانا بصفه
وزير الخارجيه وواجبي واضح جدا وهو دعم
وتعزيز
امكاناتي تحقيقيه هذه الاهداف واهداف هذه
الرؤيه الازدهار المستمر
لتحقيق ذلك في مراعي جدا ان يكون لدينا
تجاه واضح جدا ما هي الاهداف او الغايات
نستطيع ان نخوض في العديد من التفاصيل
ذكرنا احداها حقيقه اننا في هذا العام
سنصلها تريون دولار لنتج محل الاجمالي
للمره الاولى في تاريخنا وان المملكه
العربيه السعوديه مع كل التحديات التي
تواجهها هذه المنطقه نحن اسرع الاقتصادات
نموا في العالم
بين مجموعه العشرين للسيارات الخمسه
تقديراتنا
والذين الخطط
التي تجعلنا بحلول 20 30 ام من بين اكبر
ثماني اقتصادات في العالم كله ذلك يعني
انا نعيش اوقاتا مدهشه ورائعه
العملي في الحكومه
تحت رعايه وتوجيهاتي جلاله الملك وهو صاحب
السمو ولي العهد الذين فريقه رائع والذين
طاقه كبيره داخل الحكومه على ذلك والهم من
كل شيء ونعمل ان تزورها في المملكه
وهذه الطاقه معديه الكل متحمس للمستقبل
وكل متفاعل
مع المستقبل همم
البطاله اختفت واصحابي المنازل اعدادهم في
نسب تاريخيه والان
نحن على المسار الاتجاهات تنويع اقتصادنا
بعيدا عن الاعتماد على النفق كل هذه
الاهداف التمضي بشكل مستقر الى الامام
وهذا لا يسهل فقط نجاح المملكه ايضا
انتم بلد شاب كما ذكرتنا ولكن لا ازال
لديكم بعض اهل المقاومه والمقاومه
الاجتماعيه ربما من الاجيال القديمه
كلا يتحدث عن عمري مثلا
السعوديين من عمرك ستتفاجا وكل ما تقوم به
المملكه لاننا نقوم به بشكل مدروس وبشكر
رائع جدا
قرار
وقام على منطق واضح من الارقام
اوف مس سيتي
الكل يدركه والكل متحمس حتى لا جاء
القديمه الاشخاص منهم اكبر مني
جدا واتمنى عندما تزور المملكه تيري سوف
ترى درجه تفاعل الجميع
ولكن في الختام مستوى الطاقه
اكثر ما تسمعه من الجميع ونحن بانتظار هذا
منذ سنوات جدا
القضاء وقت طويل جدا
ولكنك قضيت ما يكفينا معنا ولكن اللي
بنائه الجسور بين المسلتين وهي الشؤون
الخارجيه والشؤون الداخليه
خلص السبت
يناقشه كل الاساتذه
الاكاديميين وهل العلاقه بين
السياسات الداخليه والخارجيه من مركزك انت
اليوم كيف ترون هذه العلاقه
اساسيه اساسيه جدا كما قلت مسبقا واجبي من
قيادتي واضح جدا
سياسه المملكه العربيه السعوديه الخارجيه
هي اداه
لازدهارها المحلي هذه هي الاولويه القصوى
كيف نستطيع ان نحقق الازدهار المستدام
للشعب السعودي كل ما نفعله على صعيد
السياسه الخارجيه يجمع ركز على ذلك وهذا
يعني حمايتها مصالحنا وبنعشهاركات وكذلك
يعني المنطقه المستقره والعامنه لاننا لا
نستطيع بناء الازدهار في منطقه مطارده
وهذا ايضا يعني العامله مع اشكرك كائنه
لضمان الاستقرار العالمي لان انا شهدنا
منها اوكرانيا عنوان
في كل مكان في العالم سيكون لها الاثار
على كافه المناطق العالم فاذا ما اردنا
حمايه مساراتي لا تجاهها اهل الزاهر
متدامه يجب ان نتفاعل مع العالم واحد من
نتائج هذا الواجب هو ان نحاول نكون اكثر
تفاعل ليس فقط في منطقتنا بل عالميه بشكل
يخدم مصالحنا ومصالح المجتمع الدولي مع
التركيز يجب ان نقول على العالم النامي
لاننا نشعر بشده
ونحن بالتاكيد جزء من هذا العالم
ونرى بان الاجنده التاريخ غالبا مع حجه
بشكل يتجاهل فيها مصالح الدول
الناميه اغلب الحبيبته لكن مع ذلك هي لم
تخدم بشكل فعال تنميه مساراته تلك الدول
الناميه بشكل فعال ثاني اريد ان اكون جزءا
من الحوار الدولي
بشكل يضمن ان الجميع لديه طريقه تجاه
الازدهار حتى في سياق الاقليم اتخذنا
المقاربه
وامل على اساس جدا لا يحق جيراننا فقط
الاستقرار ايضا اذا كانت لديهم اقتصادات
الناميه واسواق متناميه فهذا يصير مثل
مصلحه ونحن ايضا
في السياسه الخارجيه
لان
معادلتكم او تركيبتكم قريبه جدا من
النقاشات التي همم اخذناها مع الدكتور
انور قرقاش يوم امس
في ما يخص سياسه مراره اللاعبين المتحده
الخارجيه فلسفتكم بشكل عام مشابهه
فاذا ما تحدث مع وزير خارجيه اي دوله في
نفس الرساله هذا مجرد انعكاس مره اخرى نحن
كتله قويه وموحده ونعمله معها بشكل مفعال
والدينا رؤى متشابهه وقيادتنا سواء كانت
الامارات العربيه المتحده المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
او قياده الدول المختلفه كلها قريب بعضها
البعض ويعملون معا ويعملون اتجاه ضمانه
الازدهار ليس فقط
وسوف نستمر الفعل ذلك
اوك جوجل
نحن سعداء المشاركه التجاربنا
لان حان الوقت اللي انهاء هذه الجلسه
شكرا
لبلادكم واتمنى ان المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
اه ستكون حاضره بشكل اكبر في مؤتمر سياسات
العالميه
في الاعوام المقبله شكرا لك جزيلا الشكر
واتمنى لك سفرا امنا
واتمنى ان تعود فيه الوقت الكافي في
الرياض
للعشاء الذي لن اشارك فيه